this is a quick video on the
remote start that i got from my honda
sport 2019
i met some guy an offer up that did it
for me for 110
um the first time i tried to attempt to
do this
i went to the dealer and they told me
it was gonna cost like 150 dollars and
then another 150
to to um activate it to program it
and he also told me that if
i program this key that my other keys
were not gonna work
so that was a lie so he wanted me to buy
two keys
and that was gonna be like 500 bucks for
so i met some guy and he told me that if
i program this remote
the other remotes will still work so
actually have now i have three remotes
and this one works and my other two
works
still so just a little heads up on that
so if you go to the dealer they try to
make you
program the remote and program that the
other ones aren't going to work
that's wrong that's not that's not true
so um all you have to do is
the press this once and then this one
that's it
so all you have to do is you press you
lock it once
and then you hold this one down
and then it starts right off so then
after that
when you point the car you really lock
your car strap to the locket
you want your car
and then you have to press the brake
it tells you right there you have to
press the brake and then just press the
start button
and then everything turns on
so that's this is a little heads up if
you go to the dealer and they try to
tell you
that if you program this remote start
key that your other keys are not going
to work
that's not true so just a heads up on
that and